welcome welcome in welcome to another
edition of Market takes I know you could
have been anywhere in the world but
you're here with me and I appreciate
that I'm your host Dion Robert Bowen
reporter for the Wall Street Journal
this is Market takes and this week we
are taking you through the three most
important things that you need to look
out for this week we got a lot of data
coming up as we prepare for our last
week before we get into the Federal
Reserves fomc meeting next week um so
I'm gonna tell you what the three
biggest reports are going to be this
week first off we've got April Consumer
Credit coming out on Wednesday we get
mortgage rates on Thursday and then
initial jobless claims that same day on
Thursday now those aren't generally
thought of as big reports but ahead of
the FED ahead of CPI I had a retail
sales all coming out next week I'm going
to tell you why you need to watch out
for all three of those reports and the
effect they could have on inflation and
as we know that is all the FED is
looking out for right now so first off
let's talk through this April Consumer
Credit report now that usually gets
released or doesn't usually that gets
released a little later in the day it's
at 3 P.M on Wednesday March we had a
jump of 26.5 billion dollars and for
April we are expecting another jump of
21.6 billion dollars on the increase
um really that without context that
doesn't mean a whole lot so let me throw
a chart up here on your screen so you
can just see what we're looking at when
it comes to credit card increases now as
you see up there on your screen just a
big increase and you see that spiking
number as we get through 2021 2022 and
then 2023 so 2383 has even risen faster
than previous years and there is a
particular data point I want to talk
through but just looking up here on your
screen you can see that big defined
pickup that really outstrips the
previous increases that we had seen in
other years you're just seeing that
Spike being a little bit more vertical
than it has been that jar just
illustrates what we have seen in terms
of Americans taking on on credit card
debt now a very interesting fact that I
haven't seen talked about very much is
for the first time in 20 years during
the first quarter of 2023 Americans did
not reduce credit card spending we have
seen a consistent theme of Americans
build up a lot of credit card spending
in the fourth quarter obviously that's
holiday time gift giving flying back and
forth travel to see family etc etc but
then in the first quarter consistently
over the past 20 years Americans reduced
that credit card debt they pay it down
in the beginning of the year we did not
see that and in fact we saw Americans
taking on more credit card debt in the
first quarter this year and that theme
looks to have continued into the second
quarter now usually like I said you get
your tax refund you pay that down so the
things that begin beginning of the year
tax refund season those things usually
going hand in hand with a reduction in
credit card debt this year we have seen
an increase in credit card debt and
actually an acceleration of the increase
in credit card debt um this is
adjustment some households are under
strain from these higher prices higher
inflation and are likely relying on
credit cards to maintain their spending
so we have seen retail sales last month
we saw pick up we've seen spending
especially on Services pickup and a lot
of folks are saying okay well that means
the economy is healthy combined with the
jobs numbers that we've seen but what it
likely means is a little bit of that of
that psychological effect that folks are
saying okay well I got a job job may not
pay enough for me to afford all the
things that I want to buy the things
that I need but I've got the jobs let me
go ahead and take out money on this
credit card I'll buy things on my credit
card paid off later well those balances
are just getting higher and higher and
higher interesting fact follow with me
I'm gonna throw a bunch of numbers out
here but follow along with it 2018
credit card debt Rose 4.2 percent 2019
credit card debt Rose 3.5 again year
over year right 2020 pandemic year
credit card debt declined by 10.9 then
2021 credit card debt Rose by 5.7
2022 credit card debt Rose by 17.4
percent and we are on Pace in 2023. in
March we had 17.9 percent in April we
had 13.6 percent now look at this chart
again let's throw this chart up here on
your screen one more time and you see
that Define that very clear acceleration
in credit card debt and we are just
seeing a huge massive pickup and that's
showing no signs of falling it is
reversing uh and and defying historical
norms and just really picking up so that
chart illustrating again just this
unusual change that we have seen in
credit card borrowing that I think is
going along with the increase in jobs
numbers that we have seen that is a new
usual usually as folks get jobs they got
more money they're paying down credit
card debt what we're seeing instead is
people taking on more credit card debt
we're also seeing delinquencies Rising
back to pre-pandemic levels so folks not
being able to pay off that credit card
debt they took on and we know that
credit card interest rates are at a
record high well above 20 percent by
some measures up to 24 so this is again
defying historical norms and at a time
when credit card debt is the most
expensive it's ever been now look want
to talk about another piece that plays
into that debt puzzle and that is
mortgage rates now take a look here at
the Freddie Mac uh mortgage rate data
now we're seeing those mortgage rates
again approaching seven percent when
mortgage rates first started picking up
in 2022 you saw home sales decline
really dive fall off a cliff but lately
we have not seen that even though we're
seeing this up and down in uh in
mortgage rates increasing decreasing but
as the 10-year treasury yield has risen
it's around 3.75 right now you see there
at the edges screen on the right side
mortgage rates starting to pick back up
now that chart just illustrates the
overall trend of mortgage rates and what
we're seeing is housing buys of new
homes and existing homes starting to
pick back up again defying even these
higher rates so even as rates have come
down and picked back up and sort of
stayed around the same level they were
at last year we are not seeing consumers
turning down uh borrowing and actually
the FED is starting to worry about this
we've seen fed Governor Michelle Bowman
just last week say quote while we expect
lower rents will eventually be reflected
in inflation data as new leases make
their way into calculations the
residential real estate market appears
to be rebounding with home prices
leveling out recently which has
implications for our fight to lower
inflation that's fed Governor Michelle
Bowman talking about hey we think this
could play into our our fight against
inflation we want to lower inflation
we're keeping rates High that's choking
off growth for businesses but folks are
taking out that debt and on the consumer
side and credit cards and into terms of
mortgages so that charges like I said
illustrating that folks are not turning
away from mortgages even as these rates
move higher last chart I want to talk to
you about is the initial jobless claims
and what we're seeing we saw this
surprisingly strong jobs report data on
Friday and we have seen initial jobless
claims really supplies we want to put up
here a chart on your screen now that
shows initial jobless claims this is not
seasonally adjusted right here you see
that big spike at the beginning of the
year and we've seen the numbers kind of
pick up and fall down but you're seeing
big big spikes in pickup when the data
is not seasonally adjusted right you see
a boom pickup oh okay that could be
worrisome now I want to put up here on
your screen the seasonally adjusted
right when smoothing out that data well
it looks a lot less worrisome you're
seeing a lot lower numbers and
consistently the trend is much more
consistently low than it has been
historically and again the FED wants to
see more jobless claims if I'd want to
see more folks filing those unemployment
claims because that's going to slow the
labor market that's going to slow down
the economy and that are just
illustrating that we have not seen once
the data has been smoothed out a big
pick up in initial jobless claims a big
pickup in folks filing for unemployment
and another big increase that we got or
another change we got that was very
meaningful was Massachusetts removed a
number of fraudulent claims from its
unemployment data and that led us to the
biggest initial jobless claims drop that
we had seen since 2021.
um the Massachusetts said quote it was
experiencing an increase in fraudulent
claim activities and unadjusted claims
fell by more than 2 000 that's big for
one state in the state that's really not
all that large so labor market has only
slowed down a little bit even with 500
basis points of Fed rate increases
that's not a good sign for the FED if
what they want to do is slow down labor
market which we know they do because
they've said as much uh fewer layoffs
mean the Fed rate hikes aren't working
and the labor market is not weakening
which means again as we've seen folks
are spending on those credit cards and
they're buying more things and the the
inflation rate is not coming down the
way they want it to listen this all
comes together in that consumers have
more jobs so they feel more confident in
taking on debt even if they can't buy
things now they say hey we'll put it on
the credit card we're seeing declining
loans from Banks we're seeing lower
personal loans and lower loans to
businesses and we know the economy is
slowing but consumers are still spending
that's keeping inflation High fed has a
big decision to make this week the
market is largely expected they're going
to hold we will see what happens at the
Fed rate conference and listen that's
going to do it for us here on Market
takes I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you were here
with me and I appreciate that I'm Dion
Robert Bowen for the Wall Street Journal
we will see you next time